[Musique]
ça vous dirait de devenir voyant voyant
sur vous-même voyant sur le monde il
existe des lieux qui ont le pouvoir de
nous rendre voyant des lieux qui nous
font voir ce que nous ne percevons pas
il en existe plus de mille en france
dans ces lieux rien de notre quotidien
ne pénètre nous ne pouvons pas y manger
nous ne pouvons pas y dormir
nous ne pouvons pas y travailler je fais
le pari que chacun d'entre vous s'y est
rendu au moins une fois dans sa vie
peut-être que certains n'y sont jamais
retournés depuis que leurs parents les y
ont traîné de force enfants d'autres au
contraire s'y rendent au moins une fois
par semaine
ne pouvant plus s'en passer
ces lieux ont un pouvoir ce sont des
amplificateurs de vision vous avez
deviné de poids je parle des musées et
si on y allait ensemble et si on la
vivait ensemble cette expérience que
nous offre le musée de devenir voyant
allez je vous y emmène vous poussez la
porte vous gravissez quelques marches
ça y est vous y êtes vous êtes dans la
première salle débat blot sont
accrochées sur les murs et il ya
peut-être quelques sculptures et là vous
ressentez vous êtes dans un temple un
lieu sacré
dédié à la seule vision tu ne touchera
pas tu ne possèdera pas mais tu verras
et ce jour là plus rien ne sera comme
avant
c'est ce qui s'est passé pour moi
lorsqu'à 11 ans mes parents m'ont emmené
dans le plus grand musée d'espagne le
prado et que je me suis retrouvé face à
une jeune infante blonde me fixant du
regard
à ses côtés le peintre en personne
pinceaux et palettes à la main me fait
face également et semble étrangement me
prendre pour modèle le revêtement
indiquent qu'ils vivent à la cour
d'espagne
il y à plus de 350 ans et pourtant je me
rappelle alors parfaitement de ce que
j'ai ressenti comme une sorte
d'abolition du temps et de l'espace
les frontières entre le tableau et la
salle dans laquelle je me trouvais avait
complètement disparu
etait-ce l'enfant qui venait me
rejoindre dans mon 20ème siècle et est
ce moi qui me retrouvais à la cour
d'espagne au xviie siècle
je ne saurais le dire mais le peintre
avait accompli un miracle l'enfant était
là devant moi et me regardait comme
jamais je ne l'avais été je me sentais
vivante et il y avait plus que cela la
cour qui entourait la jeune princesse me
semblaient curieusement proches et
bientôt la petite fille que j'étais
s'est senti de la même famille que ce
peintre d'âge mûr que c'est gouvernante
entourant de leurs soins la jeune
princesse les ménines que cette naine a
l'air grave et solennel que ce jeune
garçon jouant
avec un chien me rappelant mon griffon
de l'époque rick oui je m'étais trouvé
une famille plus grande que la mienne on
l'appelle l'humanité tout d'un coup
j'appartenais à l'humanité passées
présentes et à venir vous vous rendez
compte à ce jour là j'ai ressenti la
puissance de la peinture j'avais 11 ans
et ce n'était pas fini
vingt ans plus tard je suis prof
d'histoire de l'art dans des écoles
d'arts appliqués et jeu j'essaie
d'enseigner cette discipline avec le
plus de rigueur et de rationalité
possible et lors d'une exposition
consacrée au photographe eugène hadj est
né en 1857 est mort en 1927
je tombe en arrêt devant l'une de ses
photographies dont je lis le titre cours
de chiffonniers 10 910 porte d'ivry
mais je l'oubli aussi vite car ce que
j'ai à cet instant là sous les yeux n'a
rien à voir avec la cour des
chiffonniers je suis devant une tranchée
de verdun je vois le boyau circulent les
soldats des débris épars jonchent le sol
des baraques de fortune soutenue par
quelques fusils semble sur le point
d'être pulvérisé par la prochaine bombe
l'image est muette en noir et blanc et
pourtant j'entends le son de la
mitraille au loin comme réveiller d'un
cauchemar je reviens à mon allié à
nouveau le titre
nous sommes en 1910 à la porte d'ivry
c'est bien la cour d'un chiffonniers
mais le spectacle de cette cour dévasté
anticipe de quatre ans le drame qui
frappera l'humanité tout entière
ce jour là j'ai compris la puissance
prémonitoire de l'oeuvre d'art
l'artiste est celui qui nous rend
capables de voir de tout voir y compris
ce qui va arriver
il y a trois ans et le grand bleu qui
est venu me chercher je suis au mucem à
marseille et je présente une oeuvre de
miro à des dirigeants d'entreprise
c'est un grand format recouvert de
peinture bleue cette fois ci plus aucun
personnage auquel me rattacher lit même
d'objets la toile et traverser
verticalement par une oblique rouge et
horizontalement par une procession de
points noirs de différentes grandeurs
dans cette immensité bleus il y à la
discontinuité apportée par le noir dans
cette immensité bleus il y à l'impulsion
d'un geste marqué par l' oblique rouge
plan ligne point bleu rouge noir
tout cela paraît simple trop simple non
alors comment expliquer ce qui s'est
ouvert en moi lorsque je me suis
retrouvé seul devant cette peinture
je me suis senti libre libre devoir de
tout voir le ciel et la mer le cosmos et
les astres l'humanité en marche la vie
et la mort l'infiniment petit dans
l'infiniment grand
chaque élément ne met pas apparu
détachés du reste
tout m'est venue ensemble la peinture en
déclenchant mon imagination m'a permis
tout simplement de voir l'invisible
en cela elle m'a rendu voyante demain
c'est vous qui pousserait les portes des
musées personne pour vous forcer à
regarder personne pour vous mettre le
grappin dessus
j'ai seulement trois clés à vous
remettre la première à l'hiver les
offres qui vous plaisent mais pas
seulement la deuxième préparez vous à
cette rencontre
ce ne sera pas que les téléphones il
faudra étendre pour qu'il se passe
quelque chose
un troisième enfin prenez le temps le
temps de vous arrêter le temps de
regarder et je vous le promets elle sera
là devant vous et ce jour là plus rien
ne sera comme avant
merci
[Applaudissements]